えお待たせいたしましたはじめ社長室のコーナー
本当に
お待たせしますた2つほど言い訳をさせてください一つ目本当はで東京にいるときに
取らなきゃいけなかったんですけど慢性も東京腕の動画のと力がなくてをずだった静岡
に帰ってきてから質問こんなちゃんと考えでとろっと思ってたんですけどまぁ帰ってき
てから静岡に帰ってきてからもうちょっとバタバタすることが多くてなかなかこう失望
コーナーと
結構
ちゃんと鳥谷セカンド考えなきゃなと思っていたら
[音楽]
ブーブーられる日なんてないぐらいなんですけどちょっとこれ以上ぱどうぞ
voodoo ん水飲んで酔い
wh
久しぶりの
何なんですかうわあああ
うわうわうわうわうわ懐かしいですね
何なんですか何なんですかいやこっちが何だねうんちんですか
あちゅん神社で言えば号羊羹全力の編集
[音楽]
mar
ああああああ
ano boa tarde
全力でフィンで言ってください hey
彼ていいかいめろ生まれ3の始めちゃうねだいっ
ビッ
ダイエッ
大好き島前ベリーとか言ってるお前らはこの質問だ
絶対に選ばれる術の質問
おっぱいは好きですか第一重はじめのお母さんにオレオレ詐欺してみて取りましょう
手頃これねから母ちゃんに
まずはせ
オレオレ
オレオレ詐欺あ100万円振り込んでくれ
俺の口座に
[音楽]
これオレオレ詐欺の動画を撮っているできればあっ
ている2
まさになってください a
bl 入れてちょ
24歳今後入力します始めの留学してたっけ
留学一転のアドバイスなんかありますか僕もだし半年間6か月
イギリスに留学してたんですけど留学せっかく入ってるのに
日本人で固まっているのが一番もったいないと思うんですよ日本でで固まっていると
しゃべる言葉は全部何か他の君にいるのに日本語になっちゃうから英語をしゃべらざる
を得ない状況になって自然と英語をしゃべっちゃうと思うんでなるべく友達とか
日本人とつるまずにまあなく相談できないと一人くらいいていいと思うんですけど感が
国の人と言ったら英語がかなり著
2つするのではないでしょうか低いう留学生活を送りたかった
安居くろきちめるきしょ
それはただ木 max ないはず目社長が
第いい
本題
大
大天族ってんじゃねーごめんなさい髪の毛また金にして髪の毛金カー
考えとくねやってもかみ分け様々を染めようと思ってるんで結構ありだと思います
待ってる岡部の頭の胸どっこしどっちのんついでに触れ1ああ
[拍手]
うわあああああ
挨拶ははいまさにそれでございまーここからがまぁ本編と言っても過言ではないでしょ
僕の動画の挨拶をずっと何しようって考えてたんですけど
非常に難しいでございます魚が後年まね難しい試合だつって僕なりに色々調べてこれ
いいなと思うのを何個かピックアップしてみたんちょっと見ていきましょう挨拶決め
ちゃうとするずっと言わなきゃいけないからさーすっげー考えて遅くなっちゃって
申し訳ない
俺ははじめ興味は真面目反対いじめ初めは英語が得意だからオープニン
ています vsr 肇社長です
ピースタイの人差し指と中指をそろえた感じで敬礼
バーイ欲しいですねぇもう全部インパクトを起こしですねあかりとかなかなかですね
はじめ
分保留中折りパイアー完全にパクリやないかい
いっ
いえ実ははじめん tv へぶいでーカー初めて uber はじめ tv
yeah 会えなくて良いと思います外れ冊あのこんにちははじめそうですと山な
が好きなのにこのコメントを見てますか俺は今までのが好きですありがとうございます
こういう今までのほうがいいと言っても結構多かった
んですよねはじめの端たことはやっぱぜひはじめ閉じ
ずっと列車と頃に始めのねー芽を出すどうもじゃあ今日は god 肇社長で8強4つ
こんにちはこママ
いつもイケメン始めそうです自分で決めてやるかあのシンプルでいいですね
この動作ですね今日はあの時にパーッと手を広げます
そしてこ飯の時に足をバーってします
イケメンの時はきらん開くやつをくださいコメント長くてすいません
これ全然あと今日あの時には手をパーッとしてください
ズボン下ろしてパンツも下ろしてこんにちははじめ社長の息子ですこれどうですか
だめだ阿呆にちゃ愛と勇気だけが熱い
お金です今日は愛と勇気だけが友達
外れ社長です
[音楽]
ちんがないでくれ作業じゃないけどいい
今レジャーいる上でジャンプデー
齋藤飛鳥はこんなこと言わないよという感じですねちょっといろいろ他にもたくさん
あったんですけどありがたいして変わらずこんにちははじめ諸島ベスト山だが好きお金
十分になりはず皆さん詰まっていると思う
始め今日は挨拶なくてよくないですかとか挨拶なくてもいいんじゃないかという
コメントもあって
まあいろんな意見があったんですけどもまぁいろいろ考えます
だ開いたつけるとそれずっと入っていかなきゃいけないしすごい慎重に考えた結果なん
ですけどもまぁ挨拶は
[音楽]
とりあえずま
なくていいんじゃないかなっていうか皆に行ってないとダメとか思ってるじゃないです
か
別になくなくてもいいんじゃないかなと思ってただやっぱず分な差だしていきたいなと
思ってるんであの挨拶はないにしろ
ちょっとしたオープニングをつけることにしましたしばらく前の動画で何回か使ったと
思うんですけどもなんか赤い
画面が張っててはじめちゃんちょっと道
上でているあれ襲った今後まあオープニングというか僕の動画のスタートだよという
わかりやすいためで使っていこうかなと思っております
決起で僕 youtube でどんなでお渡していきたいかなと言うと僕の日常という
かね本当は毎日思いつきでやってるようなことをパパってやってるだけなんで奥の
追いついたこと=僕の日常なんで僕
熱情皆さんと一緒に見ていければいいなと思っているのでズっぽくなくてもパパッとか
勢社長の日常て出ると思うんでこれが出たら
はじめちょっとの動画のオープニングなんだなぁと思って言ってくれるとありがたいと
思います
本当に皆さんたくさんの質問と8挨拶
くださってありがとうございましたとしばらくはコレで頑張っていこうと思います
ほんとうとき
のて申し訳ないですねまた次の動画でお会いしましょうじゃーん
[音楽]